T
HAPPENS?
SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY IS A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBER WHO
JOINS US NOW.
YOU COULD JUST PUNCH A WHOLE
THROUGH A WOMAN'S FACE BROAD
DAYLIGHT HERE IN MIDTOWN AFTER
STABBING A WOMAN WITH A
SCREWDRIVER AND MURDERING YOUR
GRANDMOTHER AND IT'S LIKE OOPS,
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN, SENATOR?
I WONDER WHY.
>> JESSE, IT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
MYSTERY TO KNEE HOW SOME PEOPLE
MADE IT TO THE TOP OF THE FOOD
CHAIN.
I'M TALKING ABOUT OUR WOKE
LEADERS.
HERE IN D.C. AND IN SOME OF OUR
MAJOR CITIES WHO PERSIST IN
ADVOCATING DEFUNDING AND
DISRESPECTING THE POLICE AND
OTHER SUCH DUMB ASSERY.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE IN THIS WORLD -- I DON'T
KNOW WHY.
IF I MAKE IT TO HEAVEN I'M GOING
TO ASK.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE IN THIS
WORLD WHO AREN'T SICK.
THEY AREN'T MIXED UP.
THEY ARE NOT CONFUSED.
IT'S NOT THAT THEIR MOTHER OR
FATHER DIDN'T LOVE THEM ENOUGH.
THEY ARE JUST ANTISOCIAL.
THEY HURT OTHER PEOPLE.
AND THEY TAKE OTHER PEOPLE'S
STUFF.
AND WE NEED COPS TO STOP THEM.
NOW, IF WE WANT TO GET CONTROL
OF THIS CRIME PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO HIRE MORE COPS.
NEW ORLEANS, IN MY STATE, NEEDS
2,000 COPS ON THE STREET.
WE HAVE GOT LESS THAN 1,000.
NUMBER TWO, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO PAY OUR COPS.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET COPS TO
WORK IN THIS WOKE ENVIRONMENT
WITHOUT PAYING THEM.
NUMBER THREE, OUR -- AND THIS
MIGHT BE THE MOST IMPORTANT.
OUR POLITICAL LEADERS NEED TO
STAND BEHIND OUR COPS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT COPS HAVE ABOUT
60 MILLION ENCOUNTERS EVERY YEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DO SOME OF THEM GO BAD?
SURE.
ARE THERE CASES OF POLICE
BRUTALITY?
A HANDFUL.
AND THEY ARE ALMOST ALWAYS
PROSECUTED.
THE TRUTH IS THAT MOST COPS WILL
LEAVE YOU ALONE UNLESS YOU DO
ILLEGAL STUFF.
AND OUR POLITICAL LEADERSHIP HAS
GOT TO STAND BEHIND THEM.
NUMBER FOUR, WE HAVE GOT TO GET
RID OF THESE PROSECUTORS.
WHOSE MANTRA IS SEE NO EVIL,
HEAR NO EVIL, PROSECUTE NO EVIL.
AND, NUMBER 5, I WOULD TELL
PEOPLE IF YOU CARE TO, AVAIL
YOURSELF OF YOUR PRIVILEGES
UNDER THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
NOW, I HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE,
AND I MEAN IT.
I BELIEVE LOVE IS THE ANSWER.
I DO BUT I ALSO OWN A HANDGUN
JUST IN CASE.
MOST AMERICANS UNDERUNDERSTAND.
OUR WOKE LEADER DON'T.
THAT WHAT YOU ALLOW IS WHAT WILL
CONTINUE.
>> CAN I ADD JUST ONE?
WE HAVE TO TELL THE TRUTH,
SENATOR.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU.
I DIDN'T SEE ANY GUYS WEARING
MAGA HATS BREAKING THE WOMAN'S
FACE.
PISTOL WHIPPING THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND CARJACKING
THAT FAMILY IN THEIR DRIVEWAY.
I COULD BE WRONG.
MAYBE I MISSED THE RED HAT, BUT
ALL I HEAR ABOUT IS THIS MAGA
CRIME WAVE AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT.
HAVE YOU?
>> NO.
AND IT'S NOT A MAGA CRIME WAVE.
IT IS A CRIME WAVE THAT HAS BEEN
CAUSED -- LET ME SAY IT AGAIN BY
THIS -- WE HAVE GOT TO DEFUND
AND DISRESPECT THE POLICE WE
HAVE GOT POLITICAL LEADER IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO THINK COPS ARE
A BIGGER PROBLEM THAN CRIMINALS.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE RIGHT.
>> THEY DO.
THEY THINK COPS ARE GUILTY UNTIL
PROVEN INNOCENT.
WHAT YOU ALLOW IS WHAT WILL
CONTINUE.
>> Jesse: WHEN YOU THINK THE
PRISONS AND THE POLICE ARE
WRONG, THAT'S.
>> CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING
JESSE, REAL QUICKLY?
IF YOU LIKE WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD
TONIGHT, WOULD YOU GO IT MY
WEBSITE, JOHN KENNEDY.COM AND
TRY TO HELP ME OUT?
IF YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU HAVE
HEARD ME SAY TONIGHT, I HOPE YOU
WILL KEEP IT TO YOURSELF.
>> Jesse: THAT'S GOOD ADVICE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR